okay I feel quite lucky about the
previous talks that we
they complement quite well what I
today which is a particular case of a
dimensionality reduction I guess we have
seen already some examples so I'm going
to present the results of a paper of two
authors from 2003 and I will mention the
reference I guess the names are Balki
nan neo ki a but I will give this at the
end and this is the the outline of the
talk but I'm going to I'm going to warm
up with like some basic ideas then we
will go to a turmoil example then I will
explain the algorithm and I wanted to
show some examples but we have seen
already some really cool pictures today
so I'm going to shift it to the end if
that's fine with you and then I'm gonna
talk a little bit about spectral
geometry so the idea is that we will
begin with the notion of manifold but we
have already seen that is somehow a
higher dimensional surface and it should
be easier enough so that we can locally
could do calculus but the question I
mean the manifold a area is five squares
big can you give me okay it's quite big
but I'm gonna focus on the area of
sexual geometry and one of the
motivating questions of this area is
this question posted by cut is can you
hear the shape of a drum and what does
it's me
and there's operator on manifolds which
is called the laplacian and you can
think about us about it as a matrix and
as we have seen it has its aspect from
the composition which are the
eigenvalues so the question is that can
you recover somehow some information
from the eigenvalues that means of
course in a pleasant if depends on the
manifold and on a metric which is a way
of measuring distances if you are giving
the metric and the manifold you can
control the laplacian and get the
spectrum but can you go all the way
around the spectrum of them can be
thought as like frequencies or like in
in a drum shape which is our manifold so
that's the idea behind the question and
you can actually not always go back but
from
spectrum the composition you can get the
dimension of the manifold its volume and
the total is color curvature so this is
the motivating let's say setting for a
spectral geometry but we want to do
something with it apply to data science
yeah no you just take the integral over
it so the question was about this color
curvature this is just the sum of the
curvature on a manifold like the et but
anyway we want to apply this or see how
these can be related to the problem of
dimensionality reduction and this is
what we want to discuss in this talk so
the key information or like this what we
are giving our K points in our n where n
is quite big so you think about the s
presented before n was equal to 3 and
the idea is that they lie in an
underlined unknown manifold M you would
like to get somehow as close as possible
as this manifold and the King and
motivating a idea behind this out this
algorithm is that if you would know the
manifold then the eigen functions of the
laplacian actually gives you an bearings
so that means the task for the idea is
giving the data you will approximate
somehow this a manifold somehow we will
see in a minute how and then use these
eigen functions to actually construct
the embedding but we don't know the
manifold so we need to proxy it somehow
and this is the idea that this authors
had and the first step is to build a
graph out of it and as we have seen also
in the previous talk this is based on a
similarity measure so we will put let's
say for each point one node on the graph
and then we will attach an edge if they
are close together but we will need to
define that and this is what we refer to
as the graph G the next thing that we
want to do is to construct the graph
laplacian so we have seen in the
previous talk that is also used for
specter clustering but I want to spend
some time like making sense of why would
you like to consider
such a thing as a Gruffalo plus a but
once you have this in G this is just a
matrix so you can apply your linear
algebra tooling to compute the spectrum
and the eigenvalues or eigenfunctions in
this case and then you use these
eigenfunctions to construct in Bury so I
would be really happy if at the end of
the talk this three step at this four
step are clear and more less this is the
take out of the top a but I want to
start with the basic basic theorem from
algebra which is the spectral theorem so
let me just spend some minutes here so
if we are given a symmetric matrix a in
our C matrix mean that if transpose
equals itself a then I mean in general
we can't we have the notion of an eigen
value and eigen vector pair which are a
pair of vectors and colors which
satisfies that Malaysian a so this is
something that we have heard a lot this
afternoon so recall the notion of a
basis for a vector space RN this is
going to be a set of vectors which are
linearly independent and generate the
space and I'm going to say that a bit if
you solve normal if their inner product
or the distance R 1 or 0 and they're all
orthogonal so this is something from
from linear algebra what is really
interesting is that for every simit
symmetric matrix we can always construct
an orthonormal basis from the eigen
vectors and this is the spectral theorem
and it's a really really powerful
theorem as we will see more or less each
eigenvalue is real so I hope this is
just the linear algebra we need for the
talk by the way I encourage you to
interrupt me if you have any question so
so that we can all follow so a before
going to the algorithm let me recall
some properties which is not all I
really know about eigenvalues and
eigenvectors so it's about the
minimizing properties that they have
that is better a so if we are given a
symmetric matrix a we know by the
spectral theorem that we have a spectral
decomposition and a for later purposes
we would like to see you okay which
vector action I maximize the functional
eh-eh f is a vector in a product with a
species of color and I'm gonna impose
the restriction the norm to be one so
I'm saying it's unique but let's see
what can we say about this so one thing
that you could do is to try to define
the optimization problem like taking a
Lagrangian and a Lagrange multiplier and
if you let me do it roughly take the
derivative you will you can convince
yourself that if a vector maximizes then
it must be an eigenvalue of the matrix
so that means in particular that the
vector which maximize disfunctional is
actually the the eigenvector of the
associated eigenvalue and for the
meaning one it's going to be the
eigenvector of the minimal eigenvalue so
these are these two formulas just you
can take their for granted that we will
use later but now to the problem the
problem that we're going to do sort of
today is to map these four points to a
line in a clever way
so a the first thing that we a so let me
go before as mentioned in the first talk
we need to define what do we need to
conserve or like to preserve in this
mapping so we want like closed points to
stay close together
but the notion of closeness of course
depends on a distance so the distance
function that we're going to use in this
case is the first in your neighbor so
how does it work
a we have our points and the first a
near neighbor of a one is three so I put
an edge for two it's one so I attach
another edge and from a3 to it was
already one and then from four I attach
an edge to one was this construction
clear I just take the nearest neighbor
and attach an edge and we get a graph so
the step two is to construct two natural
natural matrices which actually define
the graph so this is what it's called
the adjacency matrix which is a matrix
where occurs once or zero indicating
whether there's an edge or not so this
indicates there's an edge between one
and two and this indicate there is no
edge between two and three
and on the other hand we have the degree
map which actually summarizes how many
edges each note hath so note one has
three incoming edges and the other half
one and a they step three that we wish
to clarify is that if you take this
difference and say that this is the
graph laplacian actually this is the key
a actual in this embedding problem so
we're going to define now the graph
laplacian as taking the difference
between these two matrices and in the
next step i mean now it's just purely
the algorithm and then we will see why
this actually works we consider the
generalized eigenvalue problem given by
graph laplacian times f equal lambda a
DF which is equivalent invert this D to
this other relation and then you will
need to a Phi the eigen values which you
can convince yourself are 0 1 1 and 2
and then I will consider not the
eigenvalue 0 but the next one which is
lambda 1 equal 1 and consider an eigen
vector of such one there are many I just
choose one which is in this case 0-3 1 2
so maybe I verify that this is true and
also can you guess which is the eigen
vector of the eigenvalue 0 the vector of
1
yeah so this is actually something that
we will use later so if you pluck the
vector 1 or 1 this will give you the
value 0 and if we consider these are the
coordinates I mean if we consider Y or
this eigen vector as a function which
assign to each index its associated
coordinate and we will get like I will
map 1 2 coordinate 0 minus 3 1 and 4 so
this is actually undone to so actually
this did the job of mapping what we had
in two dimensions to one dimension so
this is the basic idea of spectral
clustering of a structural embedding so
let me summarize a step 1 you construct
the graph
where you define a similarity function
there are two usual candidates you can
use either the Euclidean distance or
nearest neighbors then you can choose
weights in this case we chose the way
it's choose the weights one on the
adjacency matrix but actually you can
take these exponential or Gaussian a
weights which actually we saw before for
the expected clustering and as a spoiler
actually these coefficients or these
weights actually come from the heat
equation on the manifold that we don't
know so that hopefully at the very end
we can explain why this is a natural
choice a of course T is a parameter that
you want to fix and then you construct a
graph laplacian but for that you need
two ingredients the first one is a the
matrix T of degrees which in more more
general it's just the sum of the rows of
the matrix W a and then you take the
difference and consider that a eigen
value problem this is a matrix you
compute the eigen values and the eigen
vectors and constructing being as
follows you take out lambda 0 equals 0
which will always appear as an eigen
value if the graph is connected it will
just appear once and then you can use as
before you are going to define a
embedding of degree M meaning to a
subspace of dimension M a if you take
the first M a eigen vectors and this
will work so why does it work well the
easiest case that we actually one
struggle is just mapping everything to a
real line so assume that you have
constructed your graph which so what's
the idea how do I map it so let's see a
natural candidate would be to consider
this functional J which actually takes
the difference between the two points
which are mapped so the y-coordinates
are already in our
times to wear the weight if the weights
are 0 that means the points are far away
this function doesn't see anything but
if the W is 1 in the India in the in the
easy case then you need to minimize this
so it's natural and the key point is
that you can express this functional as
a the relation Y transpose L y where L
is the graph laplacian so this is well
say okay if I want to consider this
minimize like let's say locally
minimizing property then the graph
laplacian is actually the matrix that I
want to consider for a lot of people
that's enough argument but I want to
show that this has a deeper geometrical
significance I mean it just works so
again the problem reduced ends to find a
minimizer of of this which we can
rewrite in terms of the inner product as
L y inner product with Y and this should
let's say be similar to what we saw the
first warming a slide where we see ok up
to these conditions that I'm going to
mention later this is actually if I
consider this problem what I need to
consider is an eigenvector of the
laplacian and since I have the Eric mean
it's going to be an eigenvector of the
its lowest a I can value but we have two
restrictions the first one is this one
which is fixed a scale so it has it
doesn't have anything deep but the
second condition actually eliminates the
trivial solution y equals 1 so that
takes out the 0 eigen value and can also
be seen as a translation invariance
restriction so everything that is here
it's what we want to solve and by what
we did with the a Lagrangian we thought
we saw that this is the an eigenvalue of
this problem ok so this is how it works
for m equal 1 from M bigger than Y we
can just vectorize everything meaning
whenever we have a vector we put a
matrix and whenever you have a psalm
we've put a trace I'm gonna a
share this slide so I don't want to
spend much more time here but it just
works so again hey I wanted to show some
examples
guess which example of course the
s-curve but I'm gonna put this at the
very end because I want because we
already have seen like the shape that we
will get but I would like to comment on
how this is implemented in scikit-learn
but really about the laplacian so what's
the laplacian so if you have studied
some calculus this is a second-order
differential operator a which looks like
a the first line which is just taking
the sum of all of these its derivatives
so that's pretty nice eh and that's in
RN which is a flat space if I consider
like a surface then what it's let's say
encoding the curvature how it twisted is
there the metric so to say so when I
have a manifold then the laplacian will
be something of this sort plus some
coefficients a and lower order terms
which are complicated but we don't care
and a important and fundamental theorem
in spectral geometry is that we have a
exact same result for the laplacian as
we have for the matrix a in the matrix
case so let me state this theorem which
I will also mention that a nice
reference about a this topic so the
first thing is that L as the derivative
is that it's symmetric with respect to
the inner product which is the integral
so usually we think about inner products
about just multiplying the components
and taking the sum but we can always
generalize this as taking the integral
because the integral should mimic
somehow what are some if and if M is
compact meaning if I can't put my
surface in a box roughly speaking on the
one hand side there succeeds and
orthonormal bases on functions which
consists of eigenvalues of the laplace
of eigenvectors of the passion
moreover each eigenvalue is real so as
innocent as it might look this is a
really powerful theorem a I mean just
the fact that the spectrum is discrete
is already important because it might
happen in some cases but you don't have
like discrete numbers but just rather a
continuum so you cannot say what's the
first one and what's the second one but
in this case you can do so if we are the
prop you have the problem of embedding
unknown manifold M surface into R then
what can we do well first we need to
estimate okay what would be the idea so
we want to bound the difference of the
embedding space by something so if I
take X and set I in M which are closed
what I want to have is that on the
embedding after the embedding days
remain closed so one can actually show
that if I take a function mapping to R
then you can bound the difference of any
function by the distance on M plus the
derivative of F plus lower order terms
so basically what is let's say measuring
how much I can shrink or expand my my
points in R is the derivative of F on M
so a natural candidate will it would be
say okay let us a assume that a or what
we want is that F preserved locality on
average and I think we with respect to
the first talk let's say trying to to to
see what it's preserving it's kind of
tricky because it's really about
preserving locality in on average a so
we need to solve this problem find an F
which minimize this functional a we can
try to mimic what we did for the matrix
case and just try to put it into like
Eric mean problem so I don't know a back
for a if you guys remember from calculus
week
use something which is the Stokes
theorem which is basically the
fundamental theorem of calculus that you
can integrate a derivative to show the
following this integral actually
coincides with the inner product of the
laplacian times F of F inner product
with with F so recall that this inner
product is this integral so the
computation is not important worried but
what is important is that then if I take
the arc mean of this thing is the same
as taking the admin of this thing and we
know as if we would mimic the result
from linear algebra that it should be an
eigenvalue of the laplacian so actually
a this is a motivating or let's say
what's relating the laplacian on a
manifold which we don't know to the
graph laplacian
but the question that it's remaining is
okay you talked about something a
laplacian given on points and something
you know manifold and let's say what's
the relation well this gets a little
tricky well I want to sell I say two
ideas the first one is actually that the
laplacian is is taking a derivative on
the graph so what could be a derivative
on the graph well is defined by the
boundary operator we just take the
difference between two edges so for
example if I take any direction so I
construct a directed graph from the
graph so I put some arrows around so the
first row says okay there's an arrow
which starts at 1 and ends at 2 and the
second one is there's an arrow that
starts at 3 a begins at 1 and ends at 3
and so on
so this is the way you could mimic like
taking a derivative and then if you take
the combination which is take the
transpose of this derivative which is
what you do for the laplacian which is
dela passion is the divergence of the
gradient you get
precisely the graph laplacian so this is
how you can see it as a differential
operator a and let me talk finish the
first part of this this talk talking
about the relation with the heat kernel
so a we have seen in the previous talk
that there are some weights which are
discussion decaying functions
that also appear in the algorithm
actually it's really nice in the
original paper that they player one with
the parameter T saying okay which kind
of or I can tune this parameter to get
the better embedding but this is not
something that comes for free it
actually comes from a really geometrical
interpretation so a once you have the
manifold M you can talk about the heat
equation on it which somehow will model
the flow of let's say heat on on this
surface so if you have a say in the new
background it's the same idea for a
function which depends on the position
on X and time then you will take the
derivative with respect to a time plus
the laplacian and you equate this to 0
and you impose some initial condition if
for example at time 0 should be some
value f of X so this is the heat
equation on manifold and there's a not
really explicit but there is a trick of
finding a solution of the heat equation
and is via the heat kernel so a what
does it mean every solution of every
solution of this equation can be
expressed as the integral of a the
initial condition f times a kernel
function a and this kernel function a is
called a heat kernel I and it has a
partial explicit form so the first part
is let's say the heat kernel of the
Euclidean space which if you have
studied these I mean you have a power of
a 4pi times T to the minus dimension of
M over 2 plus this exponential
turn on the distance of the points but
on the manifold you have some
Corrections the first correction is just
a function which is one on the diagonal
and you can expand this in higher powers
of T so actually the heat kernel carries
basically all of the information of the
laplacian moreover at the very beginning
when I talk about can you hear the shape
of a drum this the way you recover for
example that they met the dimension or
the volume is through this heat kernel
expansion because what you would do with
your spectrum is build up this heat
kernel and see how this they take the
expansion when T equals infinity so to
say and you can read from the
coefficient okay this should be the
dimension this should be the volume so
through this a guy you can actually
recover all of information sold actually
with the heat kernel you can partially
hear the shape of a drum and if you do
some approximation a let's say tricks I
will encourage you to go to the original
paper for for the calculations you will
see that you can actually transform this
laplacian to something of the form D
minus W and the natural weights actually
are these exponential weights so roughly
speaking you can think okay if I take
one the way it's equal to one is I still
I get a differential operator by just
taking the boundary as we did before but
somehow let's say we can say that this
actually shows that the graph laplacian
is approximating the laplacian aid in
this unknown manifold so i hope this
gave mean i know there's a lot of
password but the essential idea is that
there is a natural way of embedding
manifolds or surfaces into low
dimensional spaces be a eigenfunctions
of the laplacian and the trick is okay
approximate your manifold with a graph
and try to do this in a discreet manner
so I guess from the theoretical point of
view this justifies the choice of wait
and let's say summarizing the what the
spectral embedding wants to do is to a
preserve locality on average so maybe
just to finish and maybe to show some a
connections to scikit-learn because of
course at the very end we want to use
this we have already seen like some
implementations but I just want to take
this example and try to do it with
Python which is somehow easy so this is
what we got I mean and for the spectral
embedding we need to construct the
laplacian so this is what we do the only
input is really the adjacency matrix
because then you did the degree images
you can take by summing the rows and
there you just need to take the
difference so the only input that you
need is this matrix W which defines your
breath yeah better we'll probably see so
this is what we have and then there's a
function which is spectral embedding
with let's say no capital letters and
this is a really general form so what it
receives is the adjacency matrix W the
number of components means where do you
want to map it I want to map this to a
line so the dimension is one a desire I
don't want to normalize the laplacian
and I want to drop the first eigen value
and okay there's a software option and
this is what we get so we get other
coordinates which are not the ones that
I have usually because these are already
normalized so I just want to verify that
this actually satisfies the eigen value
problem so I just see if the result that
scikit-learn gave me actually coincides
with analytically what I would like to
do and it's true so this is just a
simple toy model a
to show how you can implement it but in
scikit-learn you have the it's a capital
letter special embedding which is let's
say less general and that's what we have
seen today because what it inputs is
just a number of n years neighbors so
here we also have this really nice
s-curve that we can move and so this is
the example that already been studied
here and again I took this from
scikit-learn documentation which I
encourage you to do and what PCA is
doing as we've seen before it just take
the principal component so just wants to
maximize the variance so we will check
this and this and this is actually what
we get so it's not very surprising and
as we have seen before if we have now
our spectral embedding a we will get
something of this sort which is hard to
interpret what it's preserving but I
guess I I hope I can convince yourself
that it's a local average preserving
locality on average but here we have
used a six nearest neighbor so I'm going
to try 1500 can you guess which kind of
shape are we going to get if we take a
lot of neighbors
I mean somehow this is measuring how
local do I want my problem to be so this
is going to be quite global so I want to
preserve locality but your locality
means okay how close my points are going
to be but if I take a lot of points well
this becomes just a global problem so
this is like somehow two-player one with
these parameters I'm gonna share this
notebook as well and again we have the
example of the sphere that we were
teased before so here we have in the
cycle and documentation a this fear
where it has two holes this one and this
one and actually it's quite fun I don't
have time to do it here but try to close
this hole and do the embedding you'll
see and understand a little bit how does
it work
so the first thing that we can try is
PCA and what we will get is something of
this sort and it's really not surprising
because we cannot really rotate these
access to unroll this fear so let's say
this is kind of not gonna work for our
purposes but if we do it now with the
spectral embedding then let us see the
results then it's something like this so
it's unrolling this fear and you can see
one hole here one hole here this is the
boundary of the circle and this is this
lie static that we cut so let's say this
is how you can see how this is actually
unrolling and maybe to comment about the
functions I I'm not sure but I did I
guess we can just define the number of
components and the number of neighbors
so I guess this is not as flexible as
just inputting the adjacency matrix but
you can still use the let's say
lowercase function for it and so I hope
you can play around with these notebooks
with which I hope to share and lat
but not least I will indicate some
references so the first one is the paper
by baking and in yogi which I try to
follow so that if you would like to read
it you might get some hints a it's fun
to to go to the article of cut where he
posed this a question about can you see
the shape of a drum I guess if you this
is just to teach you about a spectral
geometry and if you want to have some
more details and the book of Stephen
wasn't barek it's it's quite friendly so
I hope this somehow helped you and
complement the other talks which were
great and I think I'm gonna finish with
this
[Applause]
okay thank you very much for giving our
talk I think we should have taken users
first so maybe to have the theoretical
grounding no because then you you don't
you wouldn't see where you're going and
you're okay I give values what they are
yeah it's becoming more mathematical
over why like that it's like continuous
development there was a less so we still
have time for questions our QA other
questions or remarks
okay okay three but actually you go
first and then you and then you so can
you say why these AG maps are good
choices for embedding yeah so what the
idea is that if I demand to have a bound
for locality on average then you will
have to solve this problem but this
problem is equivalent to finding the art
mean of this which is an inner product
and as we saw in this first slide if you
want to find an art mean of an inner
product this is just a very warm up this
must be an eigenvector of your operator
yeah and but even in the linear case you
can just vectorize what we did let's say
this motivate example to to motivate the
the general case what happens
what's how what happens if I take your
formulated graph how what a fully
collected graph so with all weights one
your very first example if I connect all
the edges then you will try to solve a
little problem and I guess when you get
something like PCA this is what we did
with the s so I don't I don't I would
say my intuition says that I don't know
if of course you know the same as PCA
but it will try to map it globally
sometimes it will work sometimes it
won't because I cannot map a sphere for
example to a plane there's there's
curvature obstructions for it so are you
somehow the number of neighbors or the
distant functions will tell the problem
or will define how local do I want to
remain high in for industrial
applications I often use dimensionally
dimensionality reduction using thousands
of input dimensions how does this behave
in in these large applications a
actually I don't know about the
completely complex the order of
complexity but what I saw in the first
talk it that it was pretty fast so with
respect to the the other methods I don't
know if this I mean of course it depends
on what you want but what I can say from
what I've seen and from the
documentation as the overall is quite
efficient because it's yeah morally I
mean if you just a compared to others it
can compete so but I don't know let's
say the true benefits to which scale
have you applied I confirm spectral
geometry so I haven't used this much in
real life problems but I would like to
enjoy them was medium-sized to right so
not more than you didn't have like
really huge data you were running the
embedding zone right so you also implied
yes this is my experience also to these
methods while they are really
sophisticated and can capture quite
sophisticated characteristics and the
datasets they just work on small
datasets so once you have 10k of data
points it doesn't work I don't know how
it's in higher future dimension I mean
you stated 1k
features but that's like in the machine
learning we are talking about millions
of features sometimes so there's a bit
unfortunate so are there any more
questions or remarks regarding
application of these methods no cool
then thank you very much and thank you
I'm not going to
[Applause]